11 to shoot it's to Martin laying it out
it's been the start tonight giving it
back to Davis with five to shoot taking
on and it's blocked pulled down by Mensa
they have the one timeout are they going
to take it or not they don't have the
scores on the floor it's Butler with two
seconds he's got to put it up
he wins it with the jumper
a San Diego State miracle
wow and that was his second game-winning
shot of this season nothing bigger than
that Mexico well the last time there was
an NCAA Tournament game in this building
at the same end of the floor there was a
guy named Chris Jenkins who made the
shot the buzzer went off as the shot was
in the air and look at this and his
nickname was smooth and that was smooth
seven years later he got another buzzer
beater in Houston Big Time onions
goodness I didn't know where they were
gonna go with it I wasn't sure he was
going to be able to get that shot off I
didn't know if he had the awareness but
in Panthers maybe they were saying look
you can get to the glass we're going to
take a shot from the outside but this
kid has stepped up with some confidence
that is incredible
shades of Villanova you're right
they swore the goal goodness
in this tournament gives you those
incredible Shining Moments but it also
with it comes the heartache of all
heartaches when your season ends
oh my God
it is a heartache those kids played
and left it all out there they made a
run it'll never be forgotten hey in many
respects put the school on the map then
what was it even the name Florida
Atlantic absolutely all that long ago
look at that the winner
Butler does it
he delivers at the buzzer Tracy over to
you